Racism!
OOPSIE!!!
Accidental racism
How could that possibly happen??
This is just a ridiculous subreddit
You're either racist or you're not. There's no in between!
There's never any excuses. Ever!
Now let's see what these PATHETIC posts on reddit have to say about themselves.
I am SMH'ing and disgusting right frickin' now
It's a small museum, but it really captures the Australian spirit. IMMIGRATION MUSEUM
KEEP OU-hahahaha
"This is accidentally a better piece of art than anything banksy ever shit out"
Oh that's great
It happens to the best of us what can I say?
What else do we got?
"A very interesting adjective for describing the color of a car."
OK we have: "Tango Orange",
We have "Granite Gray", "Fire Brick Red",
"Silky Silver",
And...
"Superior White"!
Interesting, VERY interesting adjective indeed!
Its just interesting! That those two words would be used together!
Jesus Christ, what kinda car is this?
I AM BUYING IT!!! No I'm just kidding, I'm kidding.
Excuse me! I would like the "Superior White" please.
Can you imagine anyone buying this? Like actual racists being like:
"Yeah I drive a superior white."
Just to be clear, I do not support these racistsism claims. Video. Memes. Okay?
So I'm pretty much legally covered from any media as well.
That's a disclaimer by the way. Just so... we're clear.
Uh..I didn't make these memes and I do not endorse these messages. I will, however, laugh at them.
"These plates are color...coded."
It's accurate because the white man is happy! 😀
Okay.. maybe that was an unnecessary comment, but it was funny okay? Let's move on
Jesus Christ. Is it hot in here or is eet joost my racism?
Baby K'Tan organic baby carrier
Hmmmmm... 😁😁😁
Hmmmmm... 😂😂😂
I have no comment whatsoever, except that it's RACIST!
Just to be clear, guys
Sive told me to review this subreddit, and he's the biggest racist I know. Alright?
So I'm pretty covered by this
"Looking to purchase a kitten under ten dollars. Must be in mint condition."
"I have a black baby" "Looking for a kitten, but thanks"
"Lul it is a kitten" STILL don't want it, but thanks.
It must be in "mint condition". What the hell does that mean?
The German race wars Oopsie! 😂😂😂
The Fast and the Führerious
Oh god... this is just a bad idea isn't it.
I didn't think it would be like this, okay? I-I don't know what I was expecting
I don't know what was gonna happen, but here we are nonetheless, and I'm definitely committing.
I'm not picking anything else to do today, okay?
I should be more responsible and pick another subreddit, uh, I'm way too deep in at this point, okay?
I'm basically reviewing this... so you don't have to.
So other people won't go to this FOUL, DISGUSTING subreddit
"If humans are 65% water, Africans are just...35...percent...human."
😂😂😂 Smash immigrants! Welcome racism!
Smash those immigrants and welcome racism!
Oh wait it's Smash racism, immigrants...
Well. I'm just confused. Which one is it?
"I'm at a grocery store and a guy looks at me then turns to his wife and says
"'Oh ya we need... naan bread". I'm always happy to help" 😆😆😆
Okay that's kinda funny
Come on, he was just memeing it as well
"Stirring a square mug creates an interesting shape of coffee"
Aaaand I'm clickin away! Alright!
The amazing race, Black family: last place
Is that their actual name? Like Black?
I'm so confused.
Celebrating single moms!
😆😆😆
Ohw... is it racist to laugh at them? I can't tell.
Where do the lines go at this? I'm not makin it
"Kanye says slavery was a choice, gets owned at the end of the video"
Gets "owned".
He gets "owned". Kanye gets "owned". Kanye gets "owned".
Oh no. Oh no no no! *sniff*
"ADD? ADHD? Sign up for concentration camp now!"
Yay! 👏👏👏 So that's what it's for! 👏👏👏
"Don't do this to my boy Franklin". Ah! Fraaanklin!
I mean at least he'll have more food on his side so...
"The only white mouse Razer makes".
Ultimate supremacy
Just checkin'. I'm just checking.
"I'm gonna say it.." The N-Word. Oh, 'cause brown flipped is n-word?
This is probably the greatest discovery the internet has ever made.
It's the ultimate meme-r.
You ever seen brown? It's basically the new 420. Or 69.
It's just that hidden epic reference that people just can't stop laughing at.
"Did you know that brown says n-word if you flip it?" Incredible!
My life has been brought new meaning.
My life- what in the world? What color?
Crazy old...
Okay? I guess that's a color. How is that unintentional?
Hahaha.. "Adobe knows what's up."
"Display all blacks accurately" OR "Display all blacks as rich blacks"
Jesus Chirst! How does this keep happening?
I guess I shouldn't be asking that question.
"Would you believe me if I told you that this was the same plaza as an Anne Franke exhibit?"
"Ju-Tox"
Moving on everybody!
HAHAHAHHA 😂😂😂
Sorry, I read it and then..
"I don't mind spiders or cockroaches, it's the MOSQUES I frickin hate"
I just love how they capitalized it as well. Those goddamn mosques!
Oh great this is Swedish so that makes it even funnier.
Lekkamrat. $12.99. $9.99.
Well I mean it's simple supply and demand really.
"Don't mix up your 'n' words!"
Don't worry, I never do.
Nucleus, Neutron, Nucleon, Nuclide.
It's easy as ABCD.
Popular: Rob the jew.
HmMmM
Oh god. Are we uploading this? Am I actually...
Black child play pen.
Oh god...
69! That's a great price!
That's the *beepboop* number.
Mexican. Chinese. Crackers.
And who said racism against white people isn't real?
Shakin. My. Frickin. Head. Right. Now.
I don't like this song. I don't like-
So keep moving on! HM
Ohhohoho...  It's so bad!
How did they not see this?
Microsoft office 2013. The basic essentials.
Microsoft office, Introductory!
Microsoft office, Advanced!
It's so obvious, I feel like it's intentional racism.
Someone just snuck it in there.
Can I get the white one?
Six different colors. Gimme the white bracelet please!
I stand for power!
I don't by the way. Just for the record, okay?
"Stop pretending your racism is patriotism."
RACISM!
I want that shirt. Where can I buy that shirt? That's a great message that I stand for.
Dove, nourishing lotion. For normal to dark skin.
Normal skin everybody!
Welcome to the normal club. Proud to be part of it.
"Got an item on World Of Warcraft today".
Sandals of the blackest... Jesus Christ!
"The placement of YouTube's play button."
Hehe 😀😀😀
Oh man...
That looks strangely a lot like Jacksepticeye.
There's an Indian version of Jacksepticeye? Goddamn!
Hey! Could you just move a little bit to the left please?
"But why? I wanna stand next to the truck."
"Just-Pl-Just-Just-Just move a little bit."
"But why? Tell me what it says."
"Just move please. Just move.. "
Heyyyy!
Good uh.. choice of silhouette as well. Jesus Christ. Oh my god. Stop.
Playable Swarm!
Playable Swarm...Chinese!
So lame!
Oh god.
"Black Panther: the only movie in all of Walmart with an anti-theft device."
Wow! 😉
Great Walmart!
The Oprah Winfrey Show! An ape has conversations with humans...
Jesus Christ!
"LEGO Marvel Super heroes minifigure- Spider-Man with white power blast".
God effin dammit, stop!
Saudiskills. Saudis...
God dammit! Stop!
Time for a bath. Clean baby!
STOP!
Did someone blink? STOP!
Really Target? Stop! Please!
Ahh God!!! Dammit it's everywhere!
It's everywhere, God dammit. Please. I can't look anymore!
*panting*
Okay. We had a good time here today.
Don't. Tell. Anyone. You saw this video.
Don't tell anyone!
No one- If no one tells anyone, the video will be fine.
It will be fine! Trust me, it's gonna be fine.
It's gonna be great. It's gonna be okay!
It'll be fine. It'll be fine!
Nah, for real, obviously it's just jokes.
And.. uh... I think what's funny about it is it's not even jokes, I mean...
You can stop making these kinds of jokes. You can forbid humor, and say that it's not okay but,
Obviously, at the end of the day, unintentional racism will always exist.
Because people are always stupid.
Just like real racism will always exist because people are stupid.
Unfortunately.
Hope that message comes across clear that...
I am 100% racisisist.
Not r- NOT.
Sorry. I thought it'd be funny if I joke, but then I realized people will just take it out of context.
So I am just going to go ahead and say, I am one hundred percent...
Goodbye everybody!
Smash like on this video if you enjoyed.
Check out merch, check out Tuber Simulator, guys, the game is still very epic.
And as always,
Brofist to ya! There we go.
I have a pimple right here and it's been there the whole video.
Hope you enjoyed that.